if you're already scared of the dark the
boogeyman isn't going to make it any
easier for you here's how the terrifying
new Stephen King adaptation ends and
what it all means
returning to work shortly after the
death of his wife will Harper is visited
by new patient Lester Billings Billings
tells him in a sequence That's the basis
of King's short story and has been
lifted Faithfully here that all three of
his children died at the hands of a
mythical monster known as the boogeyman
the short story ends with the twist that
the therapist is the Boogeyman in
Disguise returning to haunt Lester but
that's not the case here as will goes
next door to make a call to the
authorities Lester is her talking to the
Boogeyman after teenage daughter Sadie
hears this she goes looking and finds
Lester's body Lester's death and
apparent suicide appears to transfer the
curse to the Harper household as
youngest daughter Sawyer begins seeing
the monster under her bed there's no
such thing as monsters you need to grow
up eventually Sadie starts seeing the
Beast her sister is afraid of and
through Research into Lester Billings
tracks down his family home while
looking around she discovers that his
wife Rita is very much still living
there and is singularly dedicated to
killing the boogeyman for Revenge after
an elaborately staged ruse to lure It
Out of the Shadows light hurts the
boogeyman it seems she attempts to kill
it but even though the boogeyman can be
hurt it recovers easily and soon
disappears back across town into the
darkness to haunt the Harpers
his daughter spent much of the film
trying to convince him that there really
is an evil force coming for them and
eventually Will finds himself going
head-to-head with the Boogeyman after
leaving Rita's house following the
failed attack on the boogeyman Sadie
Hurley calls her father and warns him of
what's coming dad you have to listen to
me but before will knows it he's being
dragged into the basement when Sadie
arrives she rushes down and finds
herself taken captive by the monster
almost immediately it opens its jaw to
reveal a separate body crawling out to
quite literally feed on Grief however
because she understands that its biggest
weakness is light Sadie takes down the
boogeyman via some crafty thinking the
lighter that once belonged to Sadie and
Sawyer's mom which Sadie uses to smoke
pot earlier in the movie is used as a
flamethrower gasoline is poured on the
floor and the Boogeyman burns up along
with the house and the dark mold which
has covered the ceiling and the walls
since it showed up in the final scene
the family returns to therapy and openly
discusses their fears of losing each
other concluding that they can finally
adapt to life with without their mom
around but as they walk out Sadie is
called back in by the therapist who
isn't there she only sees the closet
door ajar and sounds coming from inside
rather than investigate it she decides
that's enough for one day and closes the
door so you can see that there's nothing
to be afraid of
okay the film's ending where the
boogeyman is apparently still hiding in
a therapist's closet appears to be an
intentional reference to the original
short story there Lester Billings
returns to the therapist's office after
he finds there isn't a nurse outside to
make a follow-up appointment he sees the
room is now empty but the closet door is
open just a crack with a voice inside
repeating the phrase so nice as it turns
out the therapist was the boogeyman
wearing a mask the entire time but the
sight of a closet door left a jar in a
therapist's office is as far as the
similarities between the two scenes go
in the movie we see that the therapist
is not a monstrous entity and Sadie
immediately closes the door symbolically
refusing to let the monster come back
out and into her life
there is only one bit of lore needed to
understand this iteration of the monster
it grows stronger on human misery aiming
to cause more tragedy where it's already
happened in order to consume more grief
it follows Lester Billings wherever he
goes kills his three children one at a
time and then finds itself right at home
within a family still struggling to
adjust back to normal after a mother's
death after the apparent defeat of the
boogeyman we see the family return to
counseling in a heartfelt epilogue in
which they openly discuss their feelings
and finally conclude that they can do it
without Mom it's an ending that suggests
they're facing up to the loss and
healing in a way that allows them to
quite literally lock their demons in a
closet but no matter how far removed
from grief you are it's still hard to
come to terms with that's enough to
ensure a monster that feeds on those
emotions will never be fully banished
you only need to look back at the home
of Rita Billings for proof her grief may
have transformed into Vengeance against
the being that caused it but those
emotions are still underpinned by loss
the boogeyman can get weaker but can
never be fully destroyed I think
I think it's forever
early in the film Sadie uses her
mother's lighter to smoke weed this
Memento connecting Sadie to her mother
seems to portend the boogeyman's arrival
as the monster soon returns for her in
the final act as the family fights back
in the basement the boogeyman is
eventually stopped in its tracks by the
lighter which is used to help create a
makeshift flamethrower on first glance
this appears in keeping with the
pre-established weaknesses of the
monster it can't survive when brought
into the light however it also suggests
that a more effective way to destroy the
boogeyman is to directly evoke the
memories of those you're grieving that
may sound like a reach but consider what
we saw in Rita's house earlier in the
movie we know the boogeyman can be hurt
through brutal acts of violence but it
tends to recover to full power quickly
to truly stop a creature that feeds on
Grief you need to weaponize the memories
of your lost loved ones and directly
confront your emotional trauma to stop
the creature
as the original story takes place
entirely within Dr Harper's office there
are very few similarities between the
story and the movie beyond the one scene
directly adapted from The Source
material screenwriter Scott Beck Brian
Woods and Mark Heyman opted to mostly
use the short story as an inciting
incident to get the plot rolling
additionally there is a clear difference
in characterization between the luster
Billings of the source material and the
movies luster he's portrayed as a little
shiftier in this newer iteration roaming
around the house and leaving it briefly
ambiguous as to whether he'll attack
Sadie the movie also depicts Rita
Billings for the first time and her
characterization is changed considerably
from her husband's dubious description
in the story there Lester speaks of her
with contempt for her parenting style
that he thinks would have made his
children grow up to be sissies the
reader of this movie is similarly
wracked by grief but she isn't a victim
she's motivated by Revenge refusing to
leave her four walls until she takes
down the monster that claimed her
children's lives
director Rob Savage has been on the
record about how he worked with the
small team of screenwriters to
completely renovate King's original
story into a feature-length script and
looked across the author's entire body
of work for inspiration in an interview
with sfx magazine he said this movie
attacks the source material in a way
that's different from any other king
adaptation we wanted this to feel true
to his writing me and co-screenwriter
Mark Heyman were always going back to
the warmth of character that you feel in
King's novels even when the subject
matter is dark there's that glimmer of
hope he's not a cynical writer this
quote is the best reflection of what the
movie is going for with its ending
showing the family ultimately coming
together after their grief at the recent
Los Angeles Premiere the cast were
interviewed on the red carpet about the
movie Chris Messina told reporters I
think the director did a great job
dealing with grief this is a family
who've been in hard times and they're
struggling but the boogeyman is exactly
what they need and it brings them
together this comment adds an additional
reading to the film's ending now that
they are beginning to heal as a family
unit they don't need the threat of a
monster to hold them together that
monster can comfortably remain in the
closet although this is a story directly
about a family Sophie Thatcher has
argued that the monster as a metaphor
could be interpreted in multiple other
ways telling a red carpet reporter in
any culture there's some kind of
Boogeyman and it can stand for any kind
of anxiety so you can personalize and
internalize it any kind of way that's
why the movie is Scary it's not some
specific kind of Victorian ghost it's
the boogeyman
as we can tell from the ending the door
is metaphorically left open for a sequel
if this movie turns out to be a box
office hit with several original horror
movies delivering lucrative performances
recently it would be foolish to bet
against that happening and the direction
for a sequel is clearly laid out in that
final scene a family fully comes to
terms with their grief but struggles to
keep the Boogeyman from returning to
their lives with no mid or post-credit
sequences to speak of there are no
further Clues as to how King's world
would be expanded Beyond this in a
potential sequel still it's clear that
whether or not audiences love the film
King himself decidedly does speaking at
the recent Los Angeles Premiere Savage
said King apparently had the best time
it scared the out of him he sent me
this lovely essay after about how much
he'd enjoyed the movie to have made a
movie that scared Stephen King that's a
pinch me moment so with the legendary
author on board as a fan of savages film
don't rule out his return if a sequel
ever enters development
foreign